- Bacon?
Bacon?
- Hi guys, my name is
Steven Anthony Lawrence
I was Beans on "Even Stevens."
Everybody has a Beans in their life
or they are the Beans.
If you can't think of one you are.
- That's one of the top three
fake cries I've ever heard
and two of them belong to me.
- Thanks.
I've got skills.
- You know you work five
days a week with people
for four years and it's a set like that,
you become very, very,
very, very close to people.
You know, it was like a family.
There was not a dry eye
in the studio on the last finale.
Shia has a wacky side.
Maybe I like him because I kind of have
a wacky side too, I guess.
But, you know, he has a huge heart,
he'd literally give you
the shirt off of his back.
I still lived in Fresno, actually,
when I was shooting the show.
My dad was driving me back and forth,
you know, putting a lot of miles on cars.
Shia one day just kind of
surprised me with an Xbox
on Christmas.
- Well from now on,
your name is Beans.
- Why Beans?
- Kid, a nickname is not
supposed to be logical,
see, it's supposed to be fun.
- The audition process
was pretty cool, actually.
You know, you have pre-reads
and then you have your call backs.
My thing, my personal
thing that I always did
as an actor, as a kid at least,
was I kind of feel out the room,
see if they were kind of in a rush or not,
if they were kind of connecting.
Then I'd ask if they
wanted to hear a joke.
So, I told this pirate joke.
There was a pirate on a ship,
- And the ship was a rockin' and a rollin'
and I fell off me ship.
And a killer whale came
and bit off me leg.
And I said to him "How'd
you get the hook?"
It was the first kind of
stunt thing I had to do,
they lowered me down like
"Mission: Impossible"
while the girls were sleeping.
It was the most jerry-rigged stunt ever.
It was like one of those pulley systems.
All this grip needed to do
was for me to just piss him
off one day or something,
and go (grunts).
I am still doing classes.
I do only charge 40 bucks a week.
I teach kids, I teach all ages.
Anybody that's hungry.
I think it's a big, big, big blessing
to get kids to start learning
technique at an early age
instead of just making faces
in front of the camera.
We underestimate kids.
Kids can be pretty darn smart at times.
Maybe.
Maybe, I can't actually say
anything right now about that.